et voilà que la sphère hulot puisqu'il
est accusé de viol un par plusieurs
femmes commencent à sérieusement
handicaper la campagne de yannick jadot
pour europe ecologie les verts puisque
il était un candidat putatif d'europe
écologie les verts il a été un compagnon
de ce parti pendant longtemps et on
apprend que certains savaient qu'ils
savaient les questions commencent à se
poser et cette affaire'' hulot est en
train de recreuser fossé entre sandrine
rousseau et yannick jadot là où les deux
essayait de se rabibocher pour dire
qu'il serait d'accord pour faire une
grande campagne
unifiée pour les porter des idées écolos
au pouvoir à quoi est dû ce fossé parce
que l'énergie doe pas responsable de ce
qu'a fait nicolas hulot du coup bas
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que matthieu
orphelin est la première victime
collatérale de la férule au lui qui
venait de la république en marche qu'il
a été écarté de ses fonctions de
porte-parole il la différence c'est que
madame rousseau va porter davantage
encore la parole des victimes creuser le
sillon qu'elle avait accusés beaupain
également donc yal'affaire baupin qui
étaient déjà là dans le camp écologiste
la férule hausse c'est la goutte de trop
pour les féministes écolo et je crois
que jadot lui ne prend pas peut-être
encore aujourd'hui l'ampleur de cette
crise même s'il se débarrasse d'abord de
matthieu orphelin c'est quelque chose
qui va à mon avis et c'est pas pour rien
d'ailleurs que ça tombe maintenant alors
que la campagne présidentielle commence
il va devoir s'en vont prendre d'autres
décisions dans les semaines qui viennent